sports-talk says it all when no one else
will you know what the deal is you know
I'm gonna ask questions in one go
no more fake house I like to talk about
things there's nobody else talks about
what I'm going to give you is the hard
road oh yeah
Sports talk with Glenn Harris I'm not
very PC don't dad slap it approve
Washingtonian with grassroots sports
experience we bring it to life the
people in the city
lie from you channel 8 this is for Yoda
sports car with vegetarians well it's
another hot summer in the city and that
means hydrating early and often and
making sure that you pay attention to
the quality of who are you drinking
tonight of course all we're going to
expose some of the myths about drinking
water and they can affect your overall
health no question how you doing
everybody and welcome to this is just a
Toyota Sports Talk I'm Glen Herron
starting starting your weekend with us
thank you
it's another health and fitness Friday
and we bring back one of the our
original Fitness pro dr. Eric Berg
author of the seven principles of fat
burning Chuck how you doing great thank
you been on the road and everything oh
your back or back alright but you got
something real important to talk about
and it's about drinking water I'm sure
all of you have heard your parents say
you drink water eight glasses whatever
you mentioned any videos - eight glasses
of water may not be right for all the
people you know all the time that goes
against what we've been taught well I
just want to say that it's just a lot of
controversy with this water thing
everyone's pushing this water I drink a
class size to be the guy pushing water
you have to drink your water until I
bought a machine to look at the
hydration and I find the more people
drink the more dehydrated they become
because if you think about it when you
drink water and then you urinate you are
the urine is a lot more concentrated in
all the minerals electrolytes and
proteins and that's coming out of the
body so if you drink too much water
you'll flesh out your electrolytes and
there's even a condition
called hyponatremia which basically
means you deplete all your minerals from
your heart and you get a heart attack so
this whole myth of drinking all this
water is based on just random opinion so
the key is to make sure you don't over
drink now I know it's hot out there
so drink it but water doesn't
necessarily hydrate you because it's
filtered and it's filtered through a lot
of different systems lest you buy
bottled water and then you're drinking
water without the minerals and that's
the danger of drinking too much water
without minerals yeah now tap water has
nothing in it right tap water has a lot
of stuff in it as far as bad things
clora it has chlorine and has all sorts
of stuff but it doesn't have them
minerals like growing up you had a well
you had well water yet spring water
artesian water all those minerals were
really good for us but how bad is
chlorine chlorine is very bad it's
rickets
I mean it kills bacteria but what
happens is it it's a it's a very highly
reactive chemical so you drink I mean
it's it's not good I don't like it yeah
oh how much water do we need well you
need to drink when you're thirsty I know
there's this myth that you say well our
bodies don't know when we're thirsty and
you have to you know by the time you
drink it's too late you're already
hydrated that is based on someone's
opinion it's not true you know when
you're thirsty you drink and then you
drink to your fault but this whole thing
when you're taking this gallon jug and
you're drinking drinking drinking
you're basically diluting all your
minerals in your body you start to
develop all sorts of deficiencies in
magnesium calcium and potassium and well
I go to the gym and guys bring gallons
of water a gallon audience frozen most
atomic you know castellan in here just
drink and drink if you sweat a lot well
then definitely drink but just use your
sense of thirst
you know they when you're thirsty I know
people that do not drink water at all
they don't drink it at all yeah this is
in what water do you know why they don't
like water because waters been so
filtered that there's no minerals in it
it's not satisfied we have some water
here
is called ice Icelandic this is a
glacier water from an actual glacier
Pellegrino this is from underground in
Italy these are mineral waters there's
spring waters they have mineral mineral
components and it's very hydrating when
I drink this stuff I mean like growing
up in Wisconsin we drank hard water
during the well right and that was so
satisfying when I drink filtered water
or I drink tap water or if it's filtered
it doesn't do anything for me it's just
not hydrating because the minerals yeah
yeah shall we drink filtered water
mineral water symmetry well you got a
lot of different types water you got
spring water you got hard water you have
distilled water reverse osmosis now I'm
not saying you have to buy bottled water
all the time but you should should think
about getting some good mineral water
some high-quality of course I try this
glacier water that's I'm kind of spoiled
on it now it's kind of expensive but
Pellegrino is my favorite that's
carbonated but but if you get a good
spring water I think you're gonna be
fine now get a filter in your house but
try not try to also get some good water
from a bottle bottle place yeah but you
need the minerals now if you don't have
this type of water you can also put
minerals in the water like electrolytes
yeah but make sure it doesn't have the
sugar so I do not agree that you should
drink distilled water because it pulls
all the minerals out it's like no vacuum
it'll pull everything out
spring water is the best hard water from
the well is the best what are they
selling us if the distilled water is not
good that somebody knows that while it's
filtered it's just filtered you think
you're getting something good it's like
a dollar for a little bottle it's just
filtered water just like you do on your
tap I mean it's a joke it's a room it's
like you're not getting anything now
unless it's from a spring you know you
can even taste the water should taste
almost sweet if it's the real deal huh I
can taste this and I'm gonna have you
taste it later and you just tell me what
you think but I mean I can taste well
water it's it's just it's hydrating you
know so you could drink one of these
and be searched free for two hours yes
that's what I do if I drink other water
it just doesn't do anything fun right
right oh okay yeah this XF will open up
for your health and fitness call for
doctor 703 287 1020 and all calls will
have a chance to win a copy of his book
the seven principles of fat burning and
so if it's nutrition product to see the
complete line check out dr. bird calm or
spunk Friday continues in a moment I'll
be right back hey check out dr. bird
online and take the quiz to determine
your body type at dr. Berg calm take a
look at the blogs videos and other
weight loss information from his
best-selling book which I have so
jackals got there at birth offer the
seven principles fat burner you can
schedule a consultation with him by
calling just office at seven oh three
three five four seven three three six
let's go to the first caller Mary go
ahead you on the air oh yeah hi are you
doing all right how are you all doing
okay that's good listen I just want to
mention something because I've been
drinking water and uh my my doctor told
me to drink some water to make the blood
pressure go up because my blood pressure
had gone down so I've been drinking a
lot of water you know cuz just to keep
it up I didn't know if anybody had heard
that you know okay yeah Mary what
happens is if your volume of your fluid
is too low of course your blood
pressure's going to go down one thing
you may want to consider if that does
not work to add a little bit more sea
salt in your diet if you add a little
salt then you'll retain some of that
water and it will slightly bring up the
volume higher so it's not just the water
you need the minerals okay Mary you got
that okay she's gone okay Leslie
hi my name is Leslie Ortiz I'm a
registered dietician at MedStar
Montgomery Medical Center and I have to
say most of the stuff this guy saying is
not scientifically correct and I would
like to challenge him on quite a lot of
points and I think he's selling the
public on something that's just a whole
lot of quackery well well let me ask you
this how much of your how much of your
body is pure water oh it's a lot but you
get a lot of water and mineral from the
foods that you eat our thirst is
actually a very very poor indicator of
hydration it gets a lot of elderly
people and children in trouble if they
don't drink even when they're not
thirsty the color of your urine is a
much more appropriate indicator of your
hydration status
Leslie what is your objection really
under your uh a lot of what he's saying
that maril water hold the medals out of
your body people just still just do what
mineral water to drink that's motor
using in your CPAP machine or in your
your I mean this distilled water in your
in your ironing but you don't need to
drink mineral water to get your mineral
where do you get your minerals from how
the food that you eat right so if you're
drinking a gallon of water a day what
happens is it it doesn't have the
minerals to hydrate you and so whatever
you jump drinking water doing today a
lot of people are told to push that
water drink that water and I think we're
over hydrated because there's a
condition called hyponatremia are you
here air what still happens do you think
I'm air yeah and so I have to chime in
here too because I'm her husband and I'm
also a physician and I have to say I
agree I mean this whole thing that that
regular tap water and all the stuff does
a hydrator is actually not correct at
all and any necessary well what minerals
do you think people need what
concentration of minerals do they need a
lot of the things we get or whether
they're in water or not a lot of stuff
that you drink out of the tap already
has minerals in it
most people don't drink distilled water
if the water is used for like infant
formula CPAP machines those kind of
things
sir could you identify a circle so I
wanna swing
and oh and a lot of those those minerals
you get from your food so but the
problem is that a lot is ólafur second
we want you to continue just want you to
identify yourself please oh so yeah so
my name is dr. adore teas and also from
a physician and my wife here is the
dietitian and looks and so we were just
watching this and we're just seeing a
lot of stuff that's just not actually
correct and so that was like that was
our concern is that you're giving a lot
of misleading information that people
have to buy this mineral water or
glacier water or all this bottled water
and that affects the healthier and more
hydrating when it's not more hydrated
that's all not physically or factually
correct that that's not drinks for you
you can't use the money that they would
be wasting on that water to buy healthy
nutritious foods like fresh and frozen
fruits and vegetables which is so
desperately needed being in America yeah
so here's my point I'm not against
drinking water but I think there's a
problem when people are just forcing
himself to drink and drink and drink and
drink because what happens is I'm also
my clinic I see thousands of patients
and they're forcing themselves to drink
so much water when you do the testing on
their hydration a lot of them are at too
much water retention
I've had people have this drinking water
and their ankles are swollen and they're
told by their physician that they need
to drink more water you can so the point
is that I'm not against water with your
thirsty but I am against the over
hydration of drinking so much water
that's what I'm against on okay thank
you for your call please like we like
these kinds of things the lines are open
suburbia health and fitness call with
dr. Burt 703 three eight seven ten
twenty stay with the Sports Talk Friday
consumers in a moment
that me
hey can catch all of dr. Berg's
informative videos on YouTube just
search for dr. Berg on youtube.com and
you'll find a wealth of life-changing
lectures and information at your
fingertips that for back of the dr.
Eggbert author of the seven principles
of fat-burning
reaching online at dr. Berg calm we had
two very interesting callers and more
comments yeah well I think I think the
there's this huge arbitrary opinions
based on you know people say well
there's minerals in tap water but you
know I'd like to see the references
because the filters actually filter out
the minerals and when you drink water
too much water without the minerals you
you can actually create an imbalance of
electrolytes so the thing is you just
have to think with it so but when I see
people drinking gallons and gallons of
water and then you just do the test and
they're just completely out of balance
you know you got to speak up okay
alright Don go ahead you're on the air
hey this guy here smart okay I can tell
you I don't care anybody's on top it
shows me in seventh grade okay I could
knock you over 100 six-year-old and I
can tell you this guy is very very
brilliant I went to med star they did
breathed in by he they are very
brilliant there as well this man here he
knows what he's off to the foul thanks
Don and I got to tell you they're very
smart they put they put fluoride or
fluorine or ride all kinds of things you
wanted it for our teeth no all that
stuff is poison and poisoning the kids
in the recycle water at 95% it's
considered healthy to reach drink it and
pop it back in the river for people down
river to drink about 95% of Cumberland
all the way to Hancock then from Hancock
to Hagerstown
when you get to have your sound and
direction you can't stand the smell
right oh how can you drink something
that smells like something you flush
God ray not tell me what are you drink
I'm a Don I think you're brilliant
product going above the rest in normally
that's what I watch this better dumb huh
there we go what do you drink
thank you done he's gone hey well thanks
done here's here's the thing that like
in the water they have it's actually
recycled we are we drink recycled water
and from our waste so like it's not
healthy and also the other thing about
the water I want to piggyback on what
Don said was that the amount of
medications antibiotics that are in the
water they said that they're safe I
disagree with that there's an
antidepressant medication in our waters
to apply and so if we're going to drink
excessive amounts of gallons of that
drug water with fluorine and chlorides
and chloro Danes but the chemical that
drugs is what I'm against all the
hormones I mean it's in our water supply
what about the machined and alkalizes
water
yeah so so this is another thing that
when people get the machine they start
alkalizing water
you know normally spring water is
alkaline but I don't think that's the
big factor that is good for us it's the
minerals in the water when you actually
alkalis water that doesn't have minerals
and drink that it can really throw up
your ph when i tar testing people
especially in the clinic with their
urine and their urine is supposed to be
like a six and it's a nine or because
we're drinking all the alcohol water it
throws off the entire chemistry so I'm
not crazy about that the machines that
alkalis the water if you have a machine
you know you have to justify the cost
maybe set it at 7.5 but don't set it at
8.5 or 9 mm-hmm some final thoughts from
dr. Bergin just a moment bill and
alexander you're next let's take a look
back into our sports our archival of
this date 2011 at the Nationals earned
the walk-off win over the New York Mets
3-2 at nasse Park it was a second of
four wins in a row for Washington the
Nets won go up on to finish 80 and 81
that scene under three different skipper
great job
four strikeouts in the game comes your
way this Sunday at 8 o'clock
Alex Park will take your calls and
questions about the Nats and skin
training camp so join Alex and join the
conversation
desk or stalk Athens games every Sunday
at 8 p.m. we're back with dr. Rick Berg
also the 7 principles of federal
available now on Amazon calm bill go
ahead you kick it off you on there bill
hello yeah I just want to say that uh I
agree with everything that you guys are
talking about there and I've got a
first-hand story okay about that with
I'm sorry what was that condition - of
that Katrina over-hydration yeah
hyponatremia okay there
I'm your musician playing one night a
gig with the guys and the one more band
and a Randy our bass player had
basically it was very hot day we were
playing outside and Hernan Friday night
live and he drank too much water right
um he actually tried he and that's
exactly what the medics we couldn't
actually finish the show we had to cut
off because he basically passed out on
stage we were really worried about
medics came and basically he had over
hydrated and washes his body of all the
minerals he didn't have anything to eat
I said maybe you should add a beer you
know with that or something and that's
big joke but I know what you're saying I
just wanted to say I heard the other
callers and I want to say that yeah
thank you
okay but yeah thanks for everyone is so
focused on the dehydration not the over
hydration what do you think about the
two scientists that call uh I mean I
think that you have to really look at
the source of information that they're
taught especially a dietitian they're
funded Bob the continue education by
coca-cola Burger King do you have huge
funding into teaching them certain
things so I think it's altered that's my
opinion
here's a question do you think as
educators is all two people were do you
think that they could ever change now I
think the more educated you are its
heart you become more fixing your ideas
it's harder to
be free thinking about different things
so I mean everyone has fixed ideas but
there's definitely a certain dogma
that's pushed in the medical community
about water and food and nutrition
that's a little different than an
alternative medicine well you'll be
sword fighting the rest of your career
man good well what do we get our body in
the write-up pH what do we eat well
here's the thing like some people think
they're too alkaline or too acid let me
just give you a couple things number one
if you're too alkaline you'll get you'll
get pain muscle pain if you'll get
little twitching right here you get
cramps so if you're too alkaline you
drink outside of vinegar in your water
if you're too acid your breathing you
only have a sign like you'll be like
can't get enough air yeah so you need to
take calcium citrate for that and
there's other symptoms as well
shake go ahead you on there oh wow hi I
just wanted to say that I think this
topic is great
and I live in the Brandywine Maryland
area and I'd like to know if they we
have well water here but right now we
are in a series of a time period we're
assessing the water to make sure that
there's no bacteria and letting it in
terms like that but in the interim I'd
like to know if there is a brand that
you guys would suggest that is actually
a real spring water that actually runs
on them as you know still retains the
minerals and everything like that and
isn't cover haven't been affected by the
antibiotics and everything that's in the
water
thank you I should do the quick yeah
quickly I like Deer Park is good but
Pellegrino is the is the bomb it's the
best Pellegrino's from Italy it's the
real stuff all right
hey that's going to do it for this to
the sports all thanks for joining us for
Doc Eric Burdon tired from Lynn Harris
please go in French you're back again a
good one we'll see you next week
my from you channeling this is Toyota
Sports Talk
you